hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to transistor now this video
is going to be very different from my
normal ones mostly because it's not a
horror game and it's not just a silly
game that I can play once this is
transistor made by the same guy that
made Bastion which is a beautiful game
that I tried to play on a live stream
but I wasn't able to complete for
various reasons but this is a new game
made by the same guy and it features a
top-down isometric view like the other
one with RPG elements hello probably not
that guy is very dead so this is
different because it's gonna be more of
a first look in a review I want to give
you guys an idea of whether Paul I'll
try if I can transistor 1 killed today
there we go
together again yes indeed sorta yeah
you're kind of a sward but either way
top-down isometric RPG with a lot of
just really pretty artistic styling here
us already know okey dokey
go on to me back this guy do I have to
slap him around with my circuit board
sward over here come here you uh-huh yes
oh hello again
well then I got your number here now
I did play Bastion on my own I don't
know if I told you guys that it is an
incredibly unmarked alley east of the
bay if you say so
now I haven't played this one in
particular but of it I expect it to be
fairly similar but not too similar to
Bastion it's already a little bit
different but kind of feels the same
friend just whoa what happened oh my god
ah so this is the different element of
the game here there's like a oh man what
is it's like is this like Final Fantasy
Tactics contrary to popular belief I do
have good taste in games although some
people would very much disagree with
that it's like a combination of the new
XCOM game and Final Fantasy Tactics
there's free movement okay so I'm
recharging ah oh I see okay so I have a
charge up meter that allows me to go
into this really interesting warp move
world and I can plan out my move so that
they can have maximum effectiveness I'm
guessing then I press space - oh that is
cool
oh that is so cool I'm guessing that I
could also do it freeform there's also
there was a mechanic similar to that in
Dragon Age where you could pause the
game plan out your move it's not just in
dragon age of course but I mean it was
necessary necessary in the original
Dragon Age to very much plan out your
moves so this game could potentially be
an incredibly hard adventure thank you
mr. transistor sward breakpoint I love
the way visit yes up where hello world
hello look at all that yes indeed a
ninja town blocks away very cool uh
telescope now I like the way that this
game drops you right into the action
without giving any pause for a main menu
it was like as soon as I open up the
game still too close to it yes I get as
far from there as possible you got it
I always liked it when a game drops you
immediately into the narrative there is
literally nothing getting in the way of
you going into this story and that's
actually an artistic choice for this one
didn't even have the main menu I had to
restart the progress because I think
hello that person is really good okay so
I can pause hold right trigger to aim so
if I aim for that guy I should be able
to hit all ha Boesky I miss one
come on charge up charge up chart up
there we go all right so I'm guessing
they're gonna want me to use this for
most of the time but I don't think this
is on very hard difficulty that I got
like a double shot in there that's so
cool there's like a fight scene it's all
in the same world she's uh she might be
dead what does it mean processed hi you
okay hello you all right down there
Missy sure she wants to come along we
can use her
so you weren't talking about the actual
body we're talking about the digital
portion of her soul I'll see I have no
idea that is oh my god see yes anyway
this game is 20 bucks I really want you
guys to take this video to see if it's
worth your money which I'm already
starting to recommend it by the plaza
it's you it's me
what do you mean oh I see doesn't say
Pompeii no something backwards
he owns Haley red they took your voice
huh I could have stopped
well we doing something Affairs hey
let's just go what is going on this is
so cool it's so incredibly stylized it's
a backstab for best results all right
I'll give that a try
bah bah bum the sparks whoops whoa hey
wait a minute now you get back here
don't do that to me when hide behind
things
I figure I could use the environment to
my event you got a shadow what is wrong
with you let's go yes dang it
he moves out of the way so I probably
need to shoot in various directions to
try to maximize the efficiency of what
I'm doing so maybe if I okay so if I'm
not actually hitting then I can hit in
multiple directions I'm not exactly sure
how the mechanics of it work right away
so I'm gonna try to do what I can do you
even read what the hell oh I'm over
killing those guys hey wait a minute did
I hit it I hit sash at all we moved way
down there I'm hitting the shadows it is
working I am hitting her but it's taking
a lot of time I can't I can't risk
moving too much so I'm gonna I'm gonna
target in random direction to see if
that actually doesn't he
Oh for that time he actually stands
still maybe because I wasn't actually
hitting you in the first place that
might have been an inclination to the
suckage that I am
just because I'm trying to play a good
game here what is 3 do see what would I
do
BAM you moves dammit you partially block
some of my attacks it's not working out
too well you leave a shadow in your
place I'm up I know I'm up we I'm gonna
hit in all the directions you're gonna
cover nobody yea-ah oh you moved again I
got ya
I did it oh no oh no no no no no oh damn
it
alright let's see what we can do over
here did I move over there God is so
cool I love the stylization in games
like this Lulu
the way that it can make it unique even
though it's like you know top-down
isometric RPG it's been done before but
I mean whenever a game takes a new
direction like this it's actually very
interesting to see I goddamn it I don't
even know why I did that
how do I cancel a move are okay so I can
move them got it BAM [ __ ] get out of
here
Sok oh why are you still alive
you're just a shadows of that other guy
do you dodge no you do not so please get
out here side street due east god that's
so cool
I really wish the whole place we could
get a ride you know a place where I can
get rid I'm a I'm only gonna do one
video this as a first look but I may
play this on a live stream for the full
game because this is just exceptionally
cool here this didn't used to be maybe
not I don't recognize any of this
because I've never been here before
thank you very much I think I know what
I need to do so I need to press wait a
sec yeah I know I know I know you'd
press this queued up zip zop zu buddybop
over there and butter key say I'm some
kind of intelligent for this really
simplistic puzzle that I that I
shouldn't what o me bragging you don't
want me to brag I miss turmoil
I don't know what that makes him all
right I can barely hear right okay got
another one so I got crash breach spark
and jaunt John sounds like a fun ability
I have no idea what's going on oh no oh
no indeed cut off our escape yeah
whatever I got it I can get it let's see
what this guy Jesus stop pounding the
ground like that I don't want to even
come close to you so I'm gonna zip zop
zu buddybop around you try to keep my
distance if I do uh can I do a breach
attack oh god damn it
okay undo that no no no no oh I see I
got a highlight the ability that I want
to use and then I right-click to use it
okay so if I do this up all finishes out
this move here see what I can do
god he's a tough guy oh god he's a
thumpy thumpy gonna be something around
me this may take me a while but I'm
gonna I'm gonna figure it out okay Bob
let's see breach long range attack does
a lot of damage takes a lot of energy to
do a parent home Dave spoke D okay that
definitely does a lot of damage to him
so I should be able to get him down
relatively easily
no no no no no no no you give those
slamming hands away from me I don't want
anything to do with that yeah you stay
right there buddy stay right there
okay so back stabs in general do a lot
more damage than they do would normally
so it's almost always okay ow ow ow
so press four to use John ah I can use I
forgot that I can actually use abilities
in the natural world anyway and I don't
necessarily have to so if I just like
bom-bom-bom crash crash crash I'm gonna
oh [ __ ] get out it jerk me not me of
course I am awesome dude I hit level two
probably shouldn't be all that proud of
that but I actually am god this is cool
this game is so cool I love everything
about this what's alien yes we are
what can I do you for I am what am I
seeing
okay you're in right oh the upgrade menu
setup utility activated oh I can oh my
god it's the style of it it's a style I
can't get over the style of it it's also
techno punk
I love cyberpunk it's awesome techno
punk cyberpunk whatever you want to call
it is SIL really really cool so select
function choose a function to upgrade um
well I actually really like this uh
breach one the crash is nice but it
could have a bounce effect as well if I
give this one it also has a bounce
effect is I mean it just jumps to
another random character do I have to
specify it does it have to be in a row I
don't know what the actual thing is
sparkling so basically I'm just adding
bounce to any of these abilities making
jumps number of jumps five crash will
chain to multiple targets breach will
chain to multiple targets
this one actually stuns them that would
be nice to chain the stuns up but yeah
that would be actually pretty cool if
that has a stun function I may want to
just keep doing that good Ernie then
just one more block I want to show you
something so that means I would only
need to do one crash and then I could do
a whole bunch of other abilities that
are more damaging after their stun and
then there was stunned Jesus sorry oh
hello what are you doing here friendly
you gave me the one guy now I need to
worry about everyone else wait a minute
what what's going on here designation
jerk well thank you so much for
retaliation mode maybe that won't be so
bad when I stun yeah I think I have to
be right next to him to be able to do
this that's gonna bounce all the way to
him then I can move over here and line
up my shots to get a combo they do one
yes I can oh just one more Oh Oh didn't
bounce to stun him how's a nice combo
though worked out quite well
oh so you get over here don't even try I
get right there get right up on each
other
boom okay that's gonna bounce to you and
you let me do my explosion because I
think that's what I need man Oh me homie
I'm out here I'm out of your baby so if
I don't use up all of my combo meter
whatever that is it's not necessarily
gonna be bad because then I I just uh do
it in general caddies protected okay
that fills out there because then I can
use it to get a quicker respawn on the
next combo ability or whatever my stasis
I don't know I don't even know what it's
called
Jesus you're quick stop it with a
slamming hands you're being really weird
I don't want anything to do with you can
I even study you correctly give a crash
back stabia that should kill you right
whoa whoa oh come on me thank you
dad you're next just give me a second I
think that's my health bar down on the
bottom there I need to gather up some
I'm gonna get an epic combo going on
here
yeah that's right come closer buddy Oh
line it up like that I love you you're
beautiful you're beautiful people I need
to do another breach on these guys first
it's awful breach them they'll kill the
bull for them go boom okay nail them out
get those so they don't respawn and no
no you don't come here you [ __ ] all
right I'm gonna get you I'm gonna slam
you I'm gonna breach yeah calm oh yeah I
don't even know what the full benefit of
the stun is necessarily because there is
like downtime after they're hit anyway
yes
damnit what does happen am i actually in
the real world or what is the real world
in this game I have no idea so when I
get those access points it saves a game
I didn't get any new upgrades so I
didn't even get a level wheels detected
okey-dokey oh yeah thank you I knew that
I was planning that that's a weird whoa
like I can't tell
64 on RAM okay five blocks down take the
second right you got it
do not turn left you got it not turn
left
thanks for the lift you're welcome
transistor guy oh yeah it's beautiful
it's beautiful look at this left maybe I
really did know we're gonna skip town uh
we're going back there
where
okay they do not have a sense of okay
dang that's a big thingy wipe you out
and take whatever's left of me back to
those two big Cammarata Me's trash okay
right right
don't let me go dude I will not you're
my sworn buddy or my sward lover i wanna
make tender sweet passionate love to you
later I guess electro cyberpunk love I
don't know
god this is so cool bike uhh crash ready
business art anyway so this has been
transistor I am gonna end it here
because I once again wanted this to be a
first look to give you guys a taste of
what the game is all about I love really
interesting new unique games like this
with exceptional style for an indie game
and this is what I think would qualify
as an indie game it has so much polish
the mechanics of it are delightful the
combat is beautiful it flows
exceptionally well I haven't even gotten
to the challenging part yet and I may
play this on the live stream if you guys
really want me to so this game is 20
bucks on Steam you can decide for
yourself if it's worth it you can figure
out how long the game is through online
you could probably look at another
playthrough of it for a full playthrough
but either way this was exceptionally
cool and I really appreciate it and I
hope I did it justice on this video here
so thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more awesome
games that I played in the past leave a
like if you enjoyed this video and thank
you all so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
I'll forget what I was saying but I want
this time um with journey there's sort
of this feeling of wonder as you go
through a world that you don't know and
you're just kind of flying through the
world and just going about your business
as the world wraps around you and if I
need to play journey